this is the most beloved and feared
movie star dinosaur of all time
tyrannosaurus rex but what if i told you
that this singular creature was actually
three a recently published paper makes a
controversial claim that t-rex is
actually three different species and the
paleontologists behind it have opened up
a can of prehistoric worms that raises
three existential questions what's the
true identity of this tiny armed
predator why is it so difficult to
decipher the past and how do privately
owned specimens which are part of this
study impact our ability to do research
let's dig into how the proposal to
dethrone t-rex gets at all that starting
with a question of identity
my first call was the scott persons one
of the proponents of the hypothesis that
t-rex is actually three different dinos
the team he worked with looked at three
different lines of evidence in 30 t-rex
specimens bone girth the number of teeth
and where the fossils were found we
picked these three because they were
traits that had been identified
previously uh by other researchers and
known to potentially be informative when
they looked at these three lines of
evidence together scott said that the
girthiest dinos tended to be in the
older lower layers of rock meanwhile the
thinner ones tended to be higher up in
the more recent layers that hints at
t-rex evolution towards slimmer more
agile creatures they called the
girthiest or most robust of animals t
imperator or the emperor that is the
lower
group the older ancestral form t-rex was
somewhere in the middle and the queen or
t regina was the slimmest and most agile
of all as for the teeth tmparador we
think has got two sets a little tiny
chisel-like teeth uh in the front of its
lower jaw and then the two more derived
species have reduced that down to just
one such tooth set so the emperor has
the two and then the it's two different
king and queen have got one some
paleontologists are inviting calling the
proposal's evidence weak and
unconvincing t-rex expert thomas carr
for instance told me that many of the
differences detailed in the paper could
be chalked up to differences in age
gender or size he also said there was
too much overlap between the three
proposed species and that t-rexes are
known for losing front teeth in their
lower jaw as they age scott acknowledged
that there needs to be a lot more
research before t-rex is formally
dethroned but wherever it is that we
land in terms of t-rex's true identity
the debate is also interesting because
it brings up that second fundamental
question about why it's so difficult to
decipher the past especially when all
you have to go on is the bones of
animals that died millions of years ago
getting an animal's identity right is
important for understanding how
biodiversity has shifted over time plus
how life recovers after periods of mass
extinction t-rex roamed the earth right
before the dinosaurs were wiped off the
planet probably because of an asteroid
impact there's a lot of intelligent
inferences going on that's island
woodward she covers dinosaurs for the
wall street journal and she studied
human evolution when you find a human
ancestor in south africa on an island in
indonesia and it's similar to homo
sapiens or similar to neanderthals but
not quite the same do you lump those
together or is it a new species
researchers who lump are more
conservative whereas so-called splitters
sometimes they find a new species at at
every dig site they sort of take these
tiny variations between individuals to
indicate that these individuals belong
to different species how we define
species can also evolve as new evidence
becomes available island told me that
since t-rex starred in the jurassic park
movies in the 1990s the number of
specimens available for study has grown
and the more information that we have
the more we're able to sort of
re-evaluate pre-existing notions about
t-rex the future availability of that
information is also what makes this
three-species proposal controversial
paleontologists like thomas think that
the dinosaur fossil trade is unethical
so they won't study dinosaur specimens
that are privately owned and the new
study includes privately owned fossils
it's the fact that half the sample size
of t-rex is actually in commercial or
private hands right now that's the big
problem we could easily have a sample
size of 100 specimens but we don't he
says that threatens a cornerstone of
science the ability to replicate other
researchers work you may have heard of
stan the dino that got sold at auction
for a whopping 32 million dollars it was
part of scott's study after the
researchers studied it it went missing
for a while then in late march we
learned that stan was going to a museum
in abu dhabi abu dhabi's department of
culture and tourism said stan would
continue to contribute to education and
research and inspire future explorers
but we still don't know if that fossil
is owned by the museum we don't know if
it's owned by an individual so the green
light hasn't switched on for that
skeleton the first t-rex skeleton was
discovered over a hundred years ago and
thomas told me that it could take
another hundred years to gather enough
data to really know whether there are
multiple species of tyrannosaurus he and
other paleontologists don't buy the new
proposal but thomas told me that overall
he sees it as a good thing because
asking provocative questions is how
science moves forward he and scott
expect that in the future
paleontologists will be paying more
attention to the possibility of species
differences and that's not a bad thing